Jim Jordan is out of the race for
speaker of the house now we have new
people in the race one of whom is the
young Byron Donald's I am a candidate
officially uh we put out a notice on our
ex that telling the American people and
my colleagues that I've thrown my hat in
the ring to run for speaker of the house
he's in the race he's in the House
Freedom caucus so he's siding with the
conservatives he's uh close to president
Trump he is a favorite of at least a
good portion of the GOP base 44 years
old he was first elected to congress
only a few years years ago so obviously
ambitious guy his critics are going to
knock him and say he doesn't have the
experience he's too new he doesn't know
how to work the levers of power for
speaker of the house that's maybe the
most important thing to do any kind of
congressional leadership you got to know
what buttons to push what levers to pull
so it'll be hard I think for him to get
the requisite
support but on the flip side any
congressman who vote against him are
racist those are the rules now those are
the ru I didn't make the rules the libs
made the rules